renault christian 24 ans une alexandre
64 ans la balle 1 26 ans dalleau
jean-claude 30 ans
lambert rené 40 ans girard jean 35 ans
six des 19 célibataire de saint denis du
payré qui revient avec la tradition
vendéenne du marais synaj cherche femme
ce n'est pas la foire aux femmes de
challans mais la foire aux célibataires
de saint-denis et les célibataires c'est
une marchandise de plus en plus
difficiles à placer
on dirait qu'au départ c'était pas pour
progresser de marchandises d'ailleurs
c'est pas facile non plus et surtout à
livrer leur faut pour quand même tous
les goûts une autre notre doyen âgé de
64 ans c'est évident que il faut quand
même une personne plus jeune quand même
saveur j'espère quand même que tu leur
as qu'il faut qu'on lui eut d'ailleurs
il espère aussi quel âge avez vous
pas vous le dire quand même je vais
quand même 58 ans vous êtes le plus
jeune célibataire de saint denis du
payré oui le plus jeune de la région
enfin presque fonctionne ni quel âge
avez-vous 24 ans vous croyez que la
foire des célibataires du 6 ou vous
allez pouvoir trouver voilà votre pied
comme l'on dit mauvaise occasion
apprentis mort comme on dit ce que j'ai
été malades parfois des français jamais
il faudrait faire une chose kadri mais
on peut pas en quoi on est en liberté
j'espère trouver ce que je veux
quand je voulais une telle base elle ne
voulait pas de moi quand y en a une qui
me voulait nous on voulait pas obligés
de rester célibataire
vous avouerai que normal qu'ils sont
sans intermédiaire et vous en espérez
combien se donner à tous un dépendra du
nom de la ville d'importance la
clientèle il s'agit pas de les vendre à
la criée comme on vend du lierre
marchandises autrement bien sûr on parle
de foire mais s'agit pas de mettre aux
enchères à me comprenait
il y avait des jeunes sidy qui venait
juste que tu n'en as vu avec le marché
commun ce job
on leur remettra une a sign on en guérit
tu vous savez en rhodoïd sociale je
crois avec un numéro alors nous y aura
de syrie donc la série bleue pour les
demoiselles et série rouchon les garçons
si bien que le son lui exposera en même
temps ce qu'il y a comme comme
proposition de fait qui peut
l'intéresser et à ce moment là au lieu
de dire monsieur un tel engouement nomi
trop pour vous marier on dira bas
monsieur tel numéro vous êtes priés de
vous présenter tel numéro bleu vous
cherche
l'as
rome
sainteny fonds perdus dans les
feuillages et pourtant bien gentil celle
qui me strauss et cas où l'autre audi de
rendement
kg qui fera le commu at&t yann sommer
est allé de sa cargaison
qu'aguilera curie
savoir où mettre le mieux envers nous
dire on verra vite ou che
guevara ou
nous irons voir où
c'est bien dommage je ne validerai
interne et son carré
pater il est 9h à nuit dure et il espère
bien se tenait truies sur leurs atouts
tonge donné rendez vous cette année dans
ce cadre de verdure ne s'y joue
exactement à jour la foire aux
célibataires ordi tout ça pour les
modeuses pratique quand on est mardi
l'énergie est un jeune homme avoue dit